hi I'm Mel Fanning I'm Justin Smith and
we're the cast of all the bright places
and we're gonna be doing our first yes
first big red carpet event I wore well I
remember this but I was I was young it
was honestly probably for like was Tim
Ellen did he play Santa Claus yes
yeah Tim Allen Santa Claus movie I think
it was that I could be wrong movies
we're matching which my mom would do
this like match my sister and I'd like
overalls like I had like cheek cups I
got patches tea cup patches on me yeah
oh oh my gosh
oh we're not matching there oh my gosh
but you guys have a similar there's one
we went to it my sister's dr. Seuss
premiere thumbs up in this is mine was
MTV Movie Awards what did you wear I
wore a suit that I found in the back of
my closet and some dirty tennis shoes it
is a bat it's on first incorrect rumor
you read about yourself I like it died
so how do they do that
really yeah they kill you up yeah it's
weird I don't even know people if you
will even say anything about me
where are you know how am I talking
about everyone thinks I'm Will Smith's
son and I know everyone so much so that
I had to put it in my Twitter - wait but
like what like a long-lost son like Jay
was no there was like a video essay of
some guy I think it was that who like
was like something like this and I was
like what that's not my dad I was in a
car once and the driver was like I drove
your dad once I was like my dad anything
he's a nice guy like yeah he is a nice
guy I don't know how you know him and I
realized and your brother is really cool
too and I was like he thinks and so I
didn't I didn't have the heart to tell
them no I just like yeah he's a good guy
what is your first memory from the
of Maleficent okay definitely meeting
Angelina Jolie we were at the studios
like in London the Pinewood Studios and
I turned a corner and she had turned a
corner and I didn't know that she was
going to be around the corner like there
she was I just like had this weird like
reaction I just like went up and like
ran and hugged her like how crazy of me
to do that like she welcoming of it
though yes I think she was like bit like
well like she wasn't I guess I was so
nervous it just like overcame I was like
hey like way too I was just too much
first memory from the sub dressing world
I had just finished doing a play in New
York and we had a wrap party and we all
celebrated in the ways that people
celebrate and so I woke up the next day
and I had to get on the flight and I
missed my flight
because of the residual celebration
right and then I get on the plane I fly
to London I'll and I'm still like where
am i and then I walk walk into the
read-through where I meet Chris Pratt
and Bryce us Howard and the director and
the producers and everybody at like
Louie and I was like what's happening
like you're gonna act right now and I'm
like what and that was like my
introduction - did you good I think so I
mean I don't really sure first I was
acting from a young age so I have to but
like I don't count first kiss like on
screen like I was trying to hide that it
was like my first kiss like in this in
the in this movie was called ginger and
Rosa I was 13 I never kissed anybody and
and in the scene like I had to kiss
someone and I was trying to like be like
oh yeah I got kissed like like trying to
hide it director knew like she's like
you have not and so she actually and she
told me years later that that take she
used like a very very first take so I
have it's like on screen forever like
thanks my first kiss in real life was at
school
it's plan an arranged I was like we've
both had like free
free period and like it was also like
school was about to be out for the
summer like planned it yeah and then
afterwards I heard that it was like a
bet and I got like really mad but there
was okay and then we like games updated
looked over in the whole like English
class was like cheering me on very very
bizarre it was a community yes yours are
you a probably like my uncle I was like
no I was on to was was in a play I was
15 and it was with Emily something
something something it was a and then I
had my real first test like a week after
that with Lauren and we were on my couch
in my bedroom I did braces I remember I
really liked braces after that yeah
that's your fetish yeah not anymore
I don't like braces yes first car my
first car and I still have this car it
was my mom's Honda Accord it's silver
I don't have a car I don't drive but I
have my driver's license like I passed
the test like I just wanted I just
wanted to like win I'm like I want to
like pass a test yeah and then that's
like very much my personality all right
first thing you do when you're preparing
for a new role sometimes I like I like
to like make a playlist and just put it
with songs that remind me of the
character I think that the character
would like but it really depends my
process is you know sometimes you
actually have to learn a skill yes for a
role yeah she's interesting like I had
to learn to ice skate for somewhere when
I was in like the three months I would
go and I say isn't as you really have to
learn like something which is really
exciting that you get to do that or
learn like you know Jun English accent
or speak polish I just be polish and
something so I had to learn a skill for
this movie I to learn how to die oh yeah
and then you but you actually didn't
learn because you never know I give it
one good dive on my own and I was like I
got it and then on set I could not dive
I look like a frog first job I am Sam I
play my sister yoga my first job was at
Knott's Berry Farm
we were cool first tickets at the front
yeah but I did from one summer and then
I and then I got a job like an acting
job and I call my boss I was like I quit
and then I lost it I think first
reaction after you read the script or
book of all the bright places I mean I
loved it I just thought it was grad that
was honest
- like what teenagers are going through
around that time I read what a large -
yeah I read it when I was 14 and it was
kind of I think it was honestly before
the book was out because I never had
this dream of the book possibly one day
becoming a movie and the process for
this film has been like a lot of years
in in the making first piece of advice
you'd give someone who tried to become
an actor I was actually saved like take
every opportunity like no matter how
small the role like a background actor
like just like every little opportunity
like take those you know and learn from
them and also try to do your best cuz
you never know who's watching yeah you
had to be like resilient yeah they'd be
okay with protection there's a lot of
people I know like growing up a lot of
people great actors who quit because
they didn't want to they couldn't handle
the stress of the rejection yeah I think
like it's the people who push through
that that kind of make kids first big
role you nearly landed but it went to
someone else on friends I tried out to
be Phoebe's like kids like when wills
frozen no no no those are all Ross's kid
Oh Phoebe has triplets and then later
and there's what in one's name Chandler
the girl is named Mary and I tried out
to be Chandler and I didn't get the part
I was really young like really young but
I like boycotted the show and then later
my my sister got a part in like the very
last season her friends my family have
like a viewing part like they were psych
it was a really big
deal in my house and then like but I
would use a lot of stuff that I like
really want you get no I like if I don't
get it like it never come in there
[Music]